genannt
ob es in warendorf
auch nicht kannst du schon so und es
funktioniert diskussion
also was die leute wollen soziale
sie wird heute tagen unter diskussion
verstehen ist echt interessant
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn so eine infektionsrate gibt eine
prozentzahl ja und dann wird gesagt ja
dass man es vorher müssen uns jetzt
schützen müssen wir mit den alten leuten
wollen die ja eigentlich geschützt
werden verbringen lieber vielleicht
ihren toten mit ihren angehörigen
verbringen und her aber nochmals etwas
das zum beispiel beim chance muss ist
dass man den kauf zu senken
was soll ich da noch mal kurz vorher
bringen ich finde das ganz toll ich hab
es jetzt auch schon ein paar demos aber
sowas zu erleben dass wir eine
diskussion ist also was soll ich dazu
sagen
sie war wenn ich hier meinen bruder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie schätzen sie aber im letzten halben
jahr bis die presse die insgesamt sehr
eintönig geworden
ich gehöre ist immer die gleiche
mir fällt tatsächlich eine gegenstimme
also allgemein kommunalpolitik okay für
mich ist es vorbei sein
obwohl ich sie schätze wie sie auftreten
ich verstehe manche anliegen tatsächlich
die hier geäußert worden sind
aber hier ist auch echt gutes zeug
[Applaus]
bei uns dass ich damals gezeigt dass
paare die sich als superheld bekomme ich
ziemlich viel mädels dass viele menschen
sterben
momentan herrscht insgesamt über eine
pandemie und zwar eine pandemie der ag
die ist viel schlimmer als das was ihr
oder bevor ihr angst habt die korona der
grund ist viele menschen sterben an
suizid an die menschen wird momentan
nicht gedacht oder erschwert zahlen von
infektionskrankheiten zeigt aber eben
nicht von suizid von suiziden oder von
suizidversuchen keinen strom weil die
spalte ist mit einer mit einem auge
renten spanischen menschen
[Applaus]
sie sind auch hier auf der demopark
lassen sie ihr anliegen ich bin auf
jeden fall nicht auf diese demo hier ich
finde das absolut verstörend was hier
gerade passiert
ich wollte mir das anschauen heute aber
eben nicht als teil davon und das was
ich gesehen habe fand ich sind dass das
neonazi zusammen mit
verschwörungstheoretikern haufen
deutschland fahren völligen irrsinnigen
baron hier zusammen eine querfront
gebildet werden
besser
[Musik]
es soll nur unter solchen umständen zur
arbeit meinungsfreiheit gilt aus nicht
nur für einen bestimmten bruchteil werte
die man über die wochen und monate
gemacht
schlimm finde ich die die uns immer
sofort irgendwas unterstellen was man
meinungsfreiheit faseln
aber diese meinungsfreiheit gilt
offensichtlich nur für sie selbst und
nicht für jemanden der möglicherweise
wissen sie eine andere meinung hat und
ich finds auch schwierig zu sagen okay
da vorne laufen halt neonazis mit mit
der deutschen reichs plagge und hinten
sind die familien die wissen das
natürlich vielleicht nicht weiß ich
nicht sehen
mittlerweile sollte es aber bekannt sein
dass hier eben wirklich von ganz links
bis ganz rechts alles ist der holocaust
werden
kitzler nicht nach links und dann habe
ich will unsere truppe formiert deswegen
möchte ich dass darunter verstehen dass
ihr seid das lässt hoffen
warum ich hier hören freiheit und
grundrechte zu kämpfen weil das sehr
besorgniserregende entwicklungen leider
sind und die leute einfach das biest
sind viele bieten lassen wohnen zu
hinterfragen also das eine ziel so
einheitlich hatten die erstattung der
dieser hinsicht war das heißt die sind
ja gegen die maßnahmen die die
bundesregierung so zu sagen ich bin so
wird die backen kultur und einmal in
einer akuten zdf talk eingeladen
aufgegangen als st und 17 sie
existierten merken
[Musik]
was erzählt das alles nazis sind dass
wir für unser größer waren
das ist keine informationen was immer
das ist nur manipulation und der
desinformation
hoffentlich gewinnen ich glaube ein
schock gar nichts mehr
ich habe in den letzten jahren schon so
viel gesehen so viel gehört so viel
gespürt da muss glaube ich echt viel
passieren dass ich nach hause gehe und
sage oh gott oh gott oh gott aber ich
mache mir eher sorge um was bedeutet das
für unser land was bedeutet das für die
menschen die eben ankurbelt erkrankt
sind die sich zu recht sorgen machen in
ihre mitbürger und dass man da nicht
miteinander besser umgeht das versteht
durch mit keine andere möglichkeit als
die versammlung hier von der polizei
auch die lösen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
neu
b
nein
[Applaus]
dr
so wir haben den dreh abgebrochen weil
die situation einfach zu gefährlich
geworden ist man kann anderer meinung
sein aber man greift wie man dann